feels like you're watching an 80s movie
that you've never heard of before on amc
with your dad
and your dad is stephen king and he's
just telling like weird jokes
you know in the commercials
happy new year i am drinking the
cheapest bottle of champagne they had at
the store
i read stephen king's the drawing of the
three oh boy
i uh i was not prepared i know everyone
says that the series doesn't really get
started until drawing of the three but i
i didn't really believe them
until i read this the gunslinger you can
check out my review
i loved it i thought it had excellent
writing style i thought
it was just unique i really love the
characters of roland the man in black
and jake sometimes it didn't even feel
like a stephen king book
actually someone in the last video said
that it seems like a stephen king
blood meridian which that's actually uh
it's a very appropriate way to put it so
on to
the drawing of the three the second book
in the dark tower series
how do i if uh the gunslinger was like a
spaghetti western
like the good the bad and the ugly then
the drawing of the three
was like a hyped-up james cameron
1980s like terminator action thriller
mixed with tarantino it's such a
such a difference uh compared to the
gunslinger it's kind of like a shock and
i
now i kind of understand why people say
you know if you don't like the
gunslinger keep reading because
it seems like they're books written for
two totally different
types of readers except they're part of
the same series essentially
you can tell just in the first pages of
the drawing of the three that it's not
written in this kind of
high prose style or this very good
interesting style but it doesn't have
that kind of
gunslinger prose it is very much stephen
king you know you'll recognize the kind
of writing from all of his other books
and he feels more at home in the drawing
of the three than he does in the
gunslinger he feels more comfortable in
the pages
in his skin than he does in the
gunslinger i knew nothing about this
book coming in so
i thought okay we'll we'll have the
drawing of the three at the end of the
gunslinger we're told there's going to
be
three doors that roland will open we'll
draw
three people from other worlds so i
think okay you know
we'll open the three doors and then
we'll have an adventure afterwards
no this book is just opening the doors
and
it is a process there's rarely any gaps
in time it's just
we've got to get to this next point and
in that sense it reminds me a lot of
70s 80s action movies just kind of
gritty and tough
also really funny there's a lot of
really
funny scenes in this book but i'll get
into that later so
this is basically just going to be the
first half which is
no spoilers in the second half i'll kind
of go step by step through the book
talk about spoilers etc so first
impressions
yes i loved this i would put it up with
the gunslinger
in terms of of quality and enjoyment
took me probably two days to read it
because i didn't want to put it down
it's not too long it's probably twice as
long as the gunslinger i just i sped
right through it because there's really
no
no breaks in the story it starts off
with a bad situation
and that bad situation just keeps
progressing
this book basically just sets up the
main dynamic that we're going to be
carried
into the next book which is the
wastelands which i'm halfway through
which i love
so far i don't know if i love it as much
as the drawing of the three but it's
very good still
the gunslinger and the drawing of the
three are so damn good but
in such different ways like there's
really it's hard to compare them
feels like you're watching an 80s movie
that you've never heard of before on
amc with your dad and your dad is
stephen king and he's just telling like
weird jokes you know in the commercials
all right so now i'm gonna get into a
little bit of
spoiler talk okay that opening scene
where roland gets his fingers eaten
i'm thinking they're you know stephen
king's gonna retcon this he's gonna do
some
some kind of time traveling thing or
it's a dream or it gets taken back in
some way but no
it's just he gets his i think they're
his three fingers these fingers i think
on his right hand
get eaten off by the lobster cities on
the beach and that
is like the main plot forward momentum
in this book
it's just roland trying to survive
basically and get his medicine i loved
the realistic
quality there you know it's like yeah
we're drawing these people in but
priority number one
roland needs to get his his [ __ ]
medicine he needs to heal
or else he's going to die very quickly
having him
interact with 1970s new york city
is so much fun trying to go through with
this drug deal and make it through
customs i
i kept thinking okay there's going to be
a break in time where okay eddie gets
off the plane everything's fine and
brings him back but no it's just
next step next step next step what's the
next problem what's the next problem we
need all right we need to get through
customs all right let's figure out how
to get
the cocaine off of your body and in here
okay now we have to get the cocaine back
into your world how are we going to do
that while we're at
balazar's place i kept expecting it to
to stop at some point but it just keeps
going and the whole book
i started to dawn on me it dawned on me
that the whole book is just going to
basically be this
short section of time and it's just
going to keep going until the climax and
i thought the only part that sagged a
little bit was
the deda and odetta chapters which
started off
a bit fuzzy confusing and i you know you
start to understand more and more and i
really appreciate her character
later on but those chapters you know not
as fun because you're going after
you know this great shootout in the
leaning tower which is just
such a great shootout scene and i think
what makes that scene work so well is
the build
up but then when she's on the beach with
roland and eddie i loved that
because she is just raising hell for
them one thing that i thought was
a bit annoying was how eddie just falls
in love with odetta
very quickly i kind of was like well you
know it's the kah thing you know they're
meant to be
together or whatever i don't know so it
was okay but it just seemed
a little fast the whole book is
basically just
roland and eddie trying to and and uh
susanna trying to get up a [ __ ] beach
it's so enter entertaining to read
stephen king is able to
to draw us into the details and each new
detail is like there's a problem there's
another problem how are we going to
solve these problems and get to the next
stage
and there's so much drama between eddie
and roland that is so
fun and funny they're having so many
problems with each other
and then of course that there's like
this perfect climax that builds where
roland is in control of jack the serial
killer
using jack like the terminator like just
raising hell the action set like it's
just action set piece after action set
set piece in this book and i see why
this is such a favorite in the series
because it's so
fun even though the wastelands is is
good so far i really like it
it's just there's nothing can compare to
this kind of in your face
relentless storm of chaos overall
this series continues to blow me away
and interest me
i just feel this urge to complete the
series as fast as possible i don't know
if that urge will stay with me
when i get into the longer books later
on but right now
i just i can't see myself reading
anything else for a while so
what else can i say except um
i don't really do ratings but i would
give this a super high rating
along with the gunslinger this series so
far is just continuing
to exceed my expectations i mean i was
excited to start the series but i didn't
think i would be
still be binging the books so um i guess
i found
this the series for me anyhow thank you
all for
watching this video like and subscribe
if you have not already
yeah have a good one everyone and
happy new year